[Music]
hey everyone welcome back for another
episode of introducing
and today i am very excited because we
have jason moyer here
we're going to be talking about the
beautiful harpsichord
of course it's a keyboard instrument
which i do not play
and so i've decided to bring in jason
moy to be our expert guest
to teach us all about this fascinating
and beautiful instrument jason hey
brandon thanks for having me thanks for
uh inviting me to
talk about one of my favorite
instruments very happy to do it
jason and i have played concerts
together for a number of years
uh and i've always have i've always had
questions that i want to ask him that
there's never
time to pick his brain i know we're
always like running from one thing to
another
tuning you know so it's uh yeah this is
great to
have an afternoon to chat like this
totally and of course
jason's a fierbo enthusiast as well
and does actually own a fiorbo at least
for now yes yes
and i have a baroque triple harp on the
way so i think it's safe to say that
i'm a big fan of plucked string
instruments and i so admire what you do
brandon the fact that
you can pick up any plucked instruments
and i mean there's probably nothing
stopping you from playing harpsichord
you just need one
well don't tempt me how does one
transition to become a harpsichord
player like if i
if i was a good pianist and sat down
with the harpsichord could i instantly
play well or would i be like what is
this i think for a pianist
to come the first exposure to the
harpsichord for so many pianists
is um i think unnecessarily
traumatic because you realize
right off the bat that all of the
pianistic
instincts that you kind of
subconsciously rely on
they not only do
nothing for you expressively but they
actively work against you on the
instrument
so to really create resonance on the
harpsichord
uh and to create a beautiful tone um
your i mean as a plucked string
instrument it's so much more
uh closely related to loots guitars and
harps than
uh piano which is uh you know in some
most ways it's a percussion instrument
right so the playing techniques are are
entirely different
and granted it has keys on this
instrument
the keyboards are reversed as they are
on so many
historical harpsichords so the white
keys are black
and the black keys the sharps and flats
are
white um the harpsichord
plucks the strings using a very small
plectrum um kind of like a you know a
small wedge-shaped guitar pick
if you will and they
ride on the end of the keys on
mechanisms called jacks
so by depressing a key the jack on the
end
comes up and the plectrum
plucks the string and there's a very
ingenious
but simple spring that allows it to sort
of
bounce back on the way down and gravity
pulls the jack back
as you release the key so it doesn't get
hung
up or plucked twice and
a felt damper stops the sound
of the of the string when the jack falls
back into place
okay so it's mainly the mechanism of
producing sound is different runs
percussion with the hammers of a piano
and one's a plucking mechanism
which is why you're so welcome on this
very plucky channel
yes yes indeed are there any tricks
given the intricacies
and idioms of the harpsichord that are
just really kind of
fun and cool that you couldn't get for
example on a piano
well i think having on a large
double manual harpsichord like this you
have the two keyboards that can operate
independently
yeah in fact there are certain pieces of
music like box goldberg variations which
i have right here
which are specifically intended
for a double manual harpsichord like
this and it's because there are certain
passages
and i'll demonstrate a little bit from
the 25th variation
from the goldbergs where you have the
hands
crossing over certainly pianists do
this you know all the time today right
but
um you know mechanically on the
harpsichord
he was intending for to allow for this
so i'll just demonstrate a little
passage from that yeah please do
[Music]
that's so cool so right you have this
sort of crossover where
um you know there you could hear in one
particular passage
uh at the end of the variation there but
then you have whole pieces by
composers like francois cooper for
example
designed to take advantage of this fact
that you have the two independent
keyboards there's a piece called the
tiktok shock
or the musical representation of a clock
where the notes are your hands are
entirely
just playing exactly the same notes on
the top and the bottom
to sort of create this this mechanical
[Music]
effect
[Music]
i love it i've always heard that piece i
never knew it did that
yep what about the strings i've always
wondered
there was a time when i was just getting
into loots and things when i thought
okay so basically everything pre uh i
don't know
19th century or something like that was
got strong
and then i later on found out that
actually gut strings were played
well into the 20th century on most
guitars
and i kind of thought that for a while
that in general older strings were
always gut
but then i think i asked you on a
concert once uh harpsichords didn't
historically
use gut strings did they no i mean and
there are gut strong harpsichords they
were
called um you know uh lautenberg
right box so bach is a was a major
sort of proponent possibly
even had his hand in helping to invent
an instrument like that wow so the gut
strung harpsichord
certainly gets a lot closer to the sound
world of the loot but
i think at the same time so the
harpsichord itself as an instrument
certainly would not have been this big
the farther back you go
what we're looking at today is um
a representative of the harpsichord at
its apex
so the middle of the 18th century french
style instrument
but the harpsichord was first recorded
in literature
i think at the end of the 1300s really
then we
see in there's a sculpture and
altarpiece
somewhere in germany from the early
1400s
there's like a angel or choir boy
playing
a wing-shaped instrument um much smaller
so they would have been even small
enough to to fit on your lap
and they had they were very
they had much in common with saltery's
and other instruments like that
which were metal strung wire strung
salsa is of course played or plucked
with the fingers
but then someone had the leap to
install a keyboard mechanism to
create the instrument that we know of as
the harpsichord today
okay so there are some gut strong
harpsichords
namely the lautenberg the loot
harpsichord that bach used
but usually they are metal strung yes
yeah they would have been wire strung
i think that's the one of the defining
characteristics
let's say of harpsichord type
instruments
um you know whatever their size shape
orientation
of the strings they were always metal
strings
so on an instrument like this we see
across the treble it's all iron strings
down to just about the tenor register
when it
crosses over to two different colors of
brass
so yellow brass and red brass which give
the base notes
a bigger bloom a little bit
bigger warmth the second manual if i can
open this up to show us
on this instrument there are three rows
of jacks and
three sets of strings okay that play
the same pitches
the third set of strings is actually
half the length of the other two
and that allows us to play the octave
so i can by activating all of the stops
by pressing one key on the bottom
keyboard
you play three strings the octave
that's all in one key that's one key
[Music]
oh incredible so it is i think an
analogous
to say a baroque guitar for example
which has
multiple strings uh per course
and of course you know when played at
speed
it creates one sound as opposed to three
different sounds
and by taking you know the different
registers off
this would be
the same note with just one the upper
keyboard
can activate its own jack
wow and then we have the octave or the
forefoot we call it
which is activated by the bottom
keyboard
so already as you can see the spatial
layout
puts one row of jacks much closer to in
this case the nut
the bridges on that side and that gives
you the more nasal tone
that one would get by plucking the
guitar string
closer to the bridge right and
that is uh controlled by the upper
keyboard
and the row objects
farther away is activated by the
bottom keyboard as well as the set of
jacks that pluck the outer string so it
gives a
rounder waveform a slightly kind of
boomier
sound but while the upper keyboard decks
give the nasal sound
that is so cool
[Music]
do
[Music]
you know it's an incredible thing when
you think about all the mechanisms that
are going on just to produce
sound of this thing are just incredible
to me because in my mind
playing a string instrument is there's
just a string tied to two ends and
you're moving the string
and you might be stopping that string in
the left hand and to have all these
intricate
things happening and especially the the
double manuals and the three different
jacks
is kind of blowing my mind brandon i
think all of this
is just a way for us to
try to achieve what someone with a
finger
and a string can do right it's just
really
one of these beautiful things that you
know through
the magic of technology we can get close
to
but certainly we can never fully
replicate
the experience of a flexing instrument
without its middleman um i mean another
one of the
bells and whistles on the harpsichord
that i think might uh
tickle you is this what we call
a buff stop which creates sort of
loot or harp-like color out there now
you're talking my language
yeah there's a sort of a row of
leathers glued onto a baton here that we
can move
horizontally yeah when you engage it in
the on position it touches
one of the strings and essentially mutes
it but gives it
a wonderful loot or harp like quality
[Music]
that's gorgeous and this allows us for
example then in some of the repertoire
to contrast
the left hand the accompaniment part to
the melody in something like
this passage of bach
[Music]
that's beautiful you know i've heard
people do this but i never knew how
exactly it worked yeah it's just again
another
technological gizmo
and i think just these innovations
certainly something like this
would not be a standard it's a little
bit like a car
you know you can have automatic windows
or you know
manually rolled windows and
some instruments are much simpler but as
the harpsichord evolved and i mentioned
an instrument like this
is sort of a representation of the
apex of the harpsichord from middle of
the 18th century france
they were really interested in exploring
as
many colors as possible so things like
this arise
the many rows of jacks
and you know this continued well into
say the classical period as a means for
the harpsichord to stay
relevant as the piano which had been
invented in
the middle half of the early
1700s started to arrive on the scene
you know the piano was essentially a
harpsichord
that could play forte and piano which is
why it was called the piano forte
exactly
right and um but the harpsichord
coexisted with that for such a long long
time
so there is i believe
saying that the the term will use bells
and whistles
like it came from keyboard instruments
oh yeah from the early classical period
because like you'd have
pedals that activated bells and like you
know different stops you'd have
harpsichords
i think haydn's harpsichord had a
venetian swell
attached to the outside so jason i
expect more at our next concert
all these things to be happening it's
like one of these like one man
you know like oompa bands or something
right where you just have like the
percussion and
the kazoo yeah so
yeah all the bells and whistles oh
that's so cool when you look
inside a harpsichord it's already just
like the architecture of it it's just
incredible and i've noticed most
harpsichords happen to have kind of like
an elute
the the sound hole is filled in with a
decoration of sorts
uh this one is sort of a metal looks
almost like a metal
it's killed it yeah it's gilded with the
maker's mark
so different uh harpsichord builders
even back in historical times
would have sort of stamped their mark
in it with their initials and you know
either with an angel
or you know the lamb of god
but uh yeah so the french
style harpsichords especially had the
gilded rose some of them were actually
much
more elaborately painted throughout the
the whole soundboard would be
filled with flowers and birds and i've
seen a lot of
they often make this into a painting of
its own yes yeah the the big flat
surfaces are a perfect sort of tableau
for uh artwork and this goes back to
what we were saying earlier about
depends on how ostentatious
you want to make your instruments and
what uh what
kind of message you're trying to get
across makers today should put like
call seven seven three two nine for a
loot of your own harpsichord
it's the perfect marketing yes it's just
it's calling for it um
it might save the entire music industry
you know as we're talking i'm having
flashbacks to gigs
we've had where you've had to come with
your harpsichords so super early
and it's maybe made me realize that
maybe people don't realize
when you show up to a gig it's not often
you know oh there's a harpsichord ready
to go
you have to bring your own this whole
thing
to a gig sometimes how does one
transport a harpsichord
i think that is the question i get the
most often
when people realize or they see me
starting to pack this thing up after
concerts so yeah like blue players and
guitarists violinists harpists
heart supporters often have to travel
with their own instruments
and there are advantages to that i mean
the fact that you get to play at an
instrument that's yours that that you're
really familiar with right of course
every instrument has its own quarks
um but yeah an instrument like this uh
once closed up it's essentially just a
big
heart-shaped box it sits on a table
stand
so it's not connected to the legs
and once the top part is wrapped up it
can be turned
on its side 90 degrees and transported
that way so with harpsichords
like loots and early guitars you can
also
play in temperaments and temperaments if
you don't know are basically
it's a system of tuning where you
compromise certain notes
so you no longer have what are called
inharmonic pitches
a g sharp and an a flat are no longer
the same note
it means that you can play in certain
keys more in tune
but of course you have to sacrifice
other keys
and it's something that really works on
the on loots because you can just
move our gut frets but
how does one tune in temperaments on a
harpsichord well the harpsichord
because we don't have movable threats
and stuff it's it's one of the
most restrictive settings
in which um we can deal with
temperaments and i think that's why
there's
so much written about and
done about temperaments among early
keyboardists
certainly a work that everyone knows
like box wall tempered clavier
we are pretty sure it was his
exploration
of not equal temperament which is the
system we use nowadays on piano
but a way of treating
or setting a temperament that all the 24
major minor keys were
usable and harmonious the idea of
temperaments too
to just sort of expand on what you said
is that
by compromising the
tuning of different intervals across the
keyboard
it allows you to create
distinct tonal characteristics for each
key
yes so playing a piece in c major
it sounds it tastes very different from
playing say a piece in f sharp major
just because of where those
those intervals lie and on the keyboard
they would have set the temperament um
there's evidence that
you know well a lot of the performers
were also the composers
so if you have a temperament that
favored a set number of keys
then you just played or improvised
pieces
in those keys that you knew sounded
really good
we have evidence of a lot of keyboard
instruments that have
multiple so more than
12 keys per octave so they would have
had split
sharps the accidentals would have had as
you said
a g sharp and an a flat
which you could tune purely that blows
my mind i've seen some of those and they
look like a
such a nightmare to play yeah i mean but
i guess it's the same as you know
the the accommodations they made
for the music a little bit like the
theorbo if you have a
guitarist or someone coming to the
theorbo and
they see why are there 14 strings well
you know it's to make things easier in
some respects but
you know for us we go why are there
24 36 keys to the octave yeah and i mean
those were
not the stock and trade you know um
instruments that
people used but um we know that they
thought a lot about temperaments
and it mattered a whole lot to them
because you know
the artisans spilled a lot of ink over
it
and harpsichord builders and players
certainly had access to instruments like
that
wow
[Music]
do
[Music]
jason i'm so glad we finally got to have
this lengthy conversation i've been
wondering about all these things for so
long and uh
i appreciate you coming here to explain
all this and i think
the audience will be appreciative as
well i mean they generally get
information about the pluckies that that
i use but to bring on experts like you
to
to share the beauty of this instrument
and its history is really special so
thank you well i'm really happy for this
opportunity to share a little bit about
what i know about the instrument
certainly it's just the tip of the
iceberg right
there's so many different types of
harpsichords and
each with their own stories but uh i
think
yeah it's an instrument that um you know
we see
so often and in baroque
concerts and i hope uh our chat
demystified it a little bit for
your listeners and me too
okay well thanks and we'll see you next
time thank you
oh hello craig trumpeter from the viola
gamba video a couple weeks ago
i wanted to remind you about haymarket's
upcoming productions
of asus and galatia on october 30th
apollo and daphne
on march 5th and orlando next june
hope to see you there
[Music]
you